hey guys now you know that i've been  talking a lot about the importance of  drinking enough water on my channel on a  lot of videos  but did you know that if you don't drink  enough  your body will show you yes there are  signs that your body gives you that  tells you hey you need to drink water  fast are you one of those guys who are  always tired you don't know what's going  on you get enough sleep you do  everything you can but you're just tired  all the time  well are you drinking enough water  dehydration influences every aspect of  your health and that of course  influences your sleep as well you'll  know when you start to get dehydrated  you'll feel it your skin will be dry  your lips will be dry and you can test  your skin's elasticity take hold of the  skin on your lower arm between two  fingers and then release it after a few  seconds  normal skin will return quickly to its  normal position but dehydrated skin will  not